this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
nestled in the jungles of bali there's a
small village a little different from
the rest
[Music]
in the region of bangkala there's a
recessive gene common among the
residents that causes a much higher rate
of deafness it's been passed down
through seven generations
the total population is three thousand
three
in bangkala they are 44
deaf
in a town of 3000 normally only four or
five people would be born deaf making
bengali's proportion of deaf residents
incredibly unique
the sign language of bangladesh
[Music]
this sign language is known only to the
people of bangkala because it was
created by them
it's different from any other sign
language throughout the world
[Music]
part of town has adapted to their deaf
neighbors
the mayor speaks katakolok
the farmers speak katakulok
the teachers speak katakolok
[Music]
[Music]
in bungala i think it's very unique
because he rings and deaths
live together no
discrimination i'm very happy
to stay here now then i can help
deaf community deaf family
because they are
special for me
[Music]
you